[Music]
bleeding what what why are you bleeding
what do you mean bleeding my my my
fingers on my right hand did cut him off
okay go
go he who the is he tell me who he is
right now I I I I don't know a beekeeper
makes honey and and beehives with
Beehives what's he saying about bees I
don't know he said he was like detecting
The Hive or something oh man what the
Jesus Christ no no no no no no no
no you you want crypto NFS you want I I
got NF what what you what no don't don't
get this man don't
move you're a blessing Mr Clay this
place was crab grass and weeds and you
brought it back to
life Mrs Parker and I were friends she
was like family she was the only person
who ever took care of
me I just got a message saying that
there's a problem with my computer yes
ma'am we got
this here today she shot herself this is
private property to know what they do
here scamming the weakest in our society
buddy I'm counted three 1 2 three
there I did it for
you no you can't take it no you can't
I'm going to burn this place to the
ground will you stomp his ass
out you're telling me one man did this
the only thing you know is he's a
beekeeper a beekeeper beekeeper well
that's not
good beekeeper is a special program
outside the chain of command I protect
the hive when the system is out of
balance I correct it we have WS for
these things until they fail then you
have
me my fingers he cut them off what the
[__] bro don't move
you're Bow Down
all this is much bigger than a little
fishing
scam
going the money is going all over the
world to people in finance even
government you are a problem God damn
right I'm a
problem no way he's coming here straight
through the back entrance I forgot i'
give the fir fire is a break somebody
need to tame this
guy
die we have to kill him before he kills
his way to the
top
honey it's flammable as [__] who
know
[Music]